Donald Trump became president in 2016.
in large part thanks to voters in the
U.S Rust Belt states like Ohio and
cities like Youngstown which never
recovered from the decline of the steel
industry Ohio voted for Trump again in
2020 by some eight points High inflation
is being felt particularly harshly here
and so in a midterm election
overshadowed by an unpopular president
and a limping economy it shouldn't be
close yet the polls show Republican J.D
Vance tied with Democrat Imran and Ryan
clearly feels that Vance's closeness to
Trump is a liability he's made much
Advance shaking Trump's hand immediately
after the former president said this JD
is kissing my ass you have to have the
courage to take on your own leaders
these leaders in DC
they will they will eat you up like a
chew toy in addition Ryan and the
Democrats hope that Republican overage
on abortion restrictions may help bring
Democrats to the polls balances down
back his stance on the issue he now says
he doesn't support total ban but he has
used the example of a 10 year old girl
who was unable to get an abortion in
Ohio to Pivot to immigration that little
girl was raped by an illegal immigrant
and both the media and Tim Ryan need to
be honest about the fact that she would
never have been raped in the first place
if Tim Ryan had done his job on border
security and there is evidence that
after a summer of outrage the Ohio race
is reverting to tradition ultimately
this may well be just a referendum on
the party in power you don't think about
abortion on a day-to-day basis as you're
going to buy food or purchase gasoline
you think about the economy on a
day-to-day basis it's a constant kind of
reminder and a negative commercial
against the Democrats here in Ohio there
are several variables that may make this
race less competitive than the Democrats
initially thought not least that the
pollsters here have consistently
underestimated support for Donald Trump
if the Democrats do pick up Ohio's
senate seat from the Republicans it
would be a victory of national
importance if they lose it won't change
the Senate's balance of power but it
will be yet another sign that the
Democratic party has lost the allegiance
of working-class Voters
Al Jazeera Youngstown Ohio